if we could take a small detour
into uh philosophy is there by chance
any books authors whether philosophical
or not you mentioned sacha that stand
out to you that were formative in
some small or big way that perhaps you
would recommend to others
maybe when you were very young or maybe
later on in life
well actually yeah i you know i read the
number of existentialists
that appealed to me because they were
authentic
you know starter you know he declined
the nobel prizes we discussed but he
also uh was mocking people that pretend
to be something better than they are you
know he was living an authentic life
that is sincere
and that's what appealed to me and then
albert camille was another
french philosopher that advocated
existentialism
um you know that really appealed to me
that's probably my favorite extensious
camo
yeah yeah and he died at a young age in
an accident unfortunately
um and then you know people like
nietzsche
that uh you know broke uh
conventions and i noticed that uh
nietzsche is still extremely popular you
know that's
quite surprising uh it he appeals to the
young
people of today and the people that it's
the children it's the child-like wonder
about the world and
he was unapologetic you know it's like
most philosophers has a very strict
adherence to terminology into the
practices
academic philosophers and nietzsche was
full of contradictions and
and he just i mean uh he
it was just this big kid with opinions
and thought deeply about this world and
people are really attracted that and
surprisingly there's not
enough people like that throughout
history of philosophy
and that that's why i think this is
still drawn to him yeah to me what
uh stands out is his statement that
the best way to corrupt the mind of
young people
is to tell them that they should
agree with the common view you know and
uh
you know it goes back to the thread that
went through our discussion
yes
you